bait closures businesses closed we're
hearing that tomorrow because of this
general strike called for that these are
really let me just jump in there Natasha
I do apologize let me just jump in there
because we are going to cross over too
that Israeli Prime Minister he's making
a statement from West Jerusalem
status
dear citizens of Israel 3 000 years ago
here in Jerusalem
there was that Solomon quote
where two ladies came to the king and
both of the ladies claimed they are the
real mothers of the same child King
Solomon
they are ordered the sword
to
cut the child into two one of these two
ladies was ready for the child to be cut
but the other lady has insisted to keep
the child safe and alive
now
these days
the two parties are in a big difference
and they claim that they both the
country they both love the country and
love the child the two camps here in
Israel
are indifference and we need not this
tension to go on
foreign
we need not to cut our people into
pieces we need not to see violence in
the country and we need not both parties
to be hurt or to be hit we need not to
have this Rift people some people are
rejecting the military service which is
in itself a big crime the state of
Israel cannot stay without the defense
Army and the defense Army will never
accept people to reject the military
service rejecting the military service
means the end of our country from here
the heads of the security agency and the
military commanders to reject and to
refuse all these aspects of rejecting
the military service we need to come
contain this phenomena because we need
not to accept it those who are calling
for violence and rejecting the military
service are those who want to cut the
child into pieces but most of the
Israelis cannot accept cutting the child
into pieces dear citizens I'm not ready
at all and the other any circumstances
to cut the Israeli people into pieces
throughout months and months I have
urged for a dialogue and I have said
that I will knock every door for having
this dialogue and I remember that quite
well we all need to remember that quite
well we are not dealing with enemies but
we are all Brothers I'm saying this here
now today and in a clear way we will
never accept a civil war we are about to
have a clash within the Israeli society
and we are facing a crisis that is a
real threat to the National Unity of our
people and it is quite important and
it's quite necessary to behave with all
responsibility I have read yesterday
Dialogue on all issues in all causes and
we need to be within this part to have
the dialogue as most of our friends have
accepted this matter their dialogue
matter and whenever we have the
capabilities to avoid a civil war we
need to go for this
the same time we need to give ourselves
some time in order to reach a point
where we can vote during the second
session of the knesset we want reforms
we want balance between
authorities and Powers we need to
enhance the rights of the individuals
to the National understand the
supporters we can do this in the
candidate alone because we have the
people the people with us and dozens of
our supporters have arrived in Jerusalem
to support the reforms and to say that a
change must be there because the support
the reforms I want to say that I'm proud
of you I am proud of you you not a
second class citizen you are the ones
who went to the streets of the capital
in order for your Democratic voice to be
had by everyone
no one can silence you you have reached
this
spot
without uh being encouraged by anyone
you have done that because you love your
country and I was really touched and I
am asking you to behave with all
responsibilities and not to be dragged
at the inner circumstances to any bad
behavior no need to provoke anyone we
need to have the reforms in the
Judiciary we will never allow them to
prevent the people from their choices We
Will Never Surrender we were elected for
certain purposes and we'll do our best
to reach our goals through consensus the
citizens in Israel I want to tell them
all that we live in a generation a
Renaissance generation which is a chance
that was not available in most of the
people's history we need to build our
country and we need to build our nation
very soon we will celebrate together
uh
the religious
celebration and we will be always
together
and we will pay our condolences for the
soldiers of Israel who lost their lives
in our Nations
battles we appreciate everyone in the
security agencies who never forget their
responsibilities in defending all of us
because all of us have the same fate and
the same goal
this goal is to guarantee the existence
of Israel forever thank you very much
for every one of you thank you
foreign
yeah
so a short statement made by the Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu saying
that Israel is at a dangerous Crossroads
and he did say that he will delay the
second and third readings of that
Justice Bill to the following
parliamentary session which will take
place next month and he said that this
delay comes from a will to reach broad
consensus according to the Prime
Minister he will turn out over every
stone to find a solution and he says
that he's not ready to divide the nation
into pieces and that he's willing to
take the time out for a dialogue also
blaming an extremist minority who are
ready to divide the nation let's bring
in Natasha her name she's joining us now
from West Jerusalem so Natasha what did
you make of the statement made by the
prime minister
foreign
we will not surrender stands out he then
added as you mentioned that we will do
our best to reach our goals through
consensus the opposition leaders have
been complaining for months the three
months since this governing Coalition
came to power that they have not been
able to reach a consensus that the
Netanyahu and the governing Coalition
were not interested in having any kind
of compromise let's go back to how this
uh latest phase of The Crisis began it
began on Sunday evening when Netanyahu
ousted defense minister joov Gallant for
expressing concern about National
Security and saying that the judicial
overhaul should be halted until after
the Passover recess and the knesset
Returns on April 30th of course that's
exactly what ended up happening uh after
uh Netanyahu was placed in a very
difficult spot today but I believe that
the app position would say that they
don't believe that there is any room for
compromise I will tell you on the street
that not only are protesters saying that
they don't want this uh package this
judicial overhaul package in its current
form to proceed they want it squashed in
general and you're hearing a lot of
people saying that they're losing faith
in the ability of Netanyahu to put the
country's needs ahead of his own we left
the protest in front of the knesset a
short time ago because supporters of
Netanyahu had joined the protesters they
were chanting that the public wants this
reform they're saying that that the uh
their voices do need to be heard and
we're hearing from them that they
believe that there should be judicial
overhaul so what you have are two sides
that have continued to dig in today
despite the fact that we are in
unprecedented territory the country in
an absolute state of paralysis with a
general strike across many sectors of
society airports closed and we're
hearing tomorrow that the Israeli Stock
Exchange will also be closed so it's
very it'll be interesting to re uh
Doreen to see uh is other going to be
any after this recess any edging closer
to a consensus we have to mention that a
concession was given in exchange for a
portion of the ruling uh the ruling
coalition to sign off on this halt to
the judicial overhaul so the national
security minister itamar bengavir was a
holdout he was insisting that the
judicial overhaul needed to proceed well
we are now hearing that Netanyahu gave
him a concession and said that he would
create the formation he would create a
National Guard and that would become
something that would be part of Ben
gevir's purview and that that National
Guard would be approved in cabinet
meeting on Sunday all right Natasha
we'll let you go for now thank you
Natasha reporting for us from occupied
East Jerusalem